foreign
[Music]
so without further Ado we're playing 15
plus 10 we're playing longer games we
are putting an accent on the openings
and let's hope for a somewhat more
competitive game here we go
okay we're playing at a thousand
and I remind you that my sort of
official recommendation in this Speed
Run is the accelerated Dragon which is
actually the opening that I started with
our very first Speed Run I was almost
exclusively playing The Accelerated we
had great results and it's an incredibly
easy to learn weapon that I recommend to
a wide variety of players C4 so C4 is
already a pretty big surprise it's a
move so I've I've seen this move before
and it's not it's not a terrible move
you can almost think of this as a
transposition to an English right white
can also play C4 you can respond with C5
and then white can play E4 and move two
now the the obvious drawback of this
move and this is really the first thing
that should jump out at you is of course
the fact that white has created this
massive hole on D4
and a hole is the definition of a hole
or a weakness is a square that cannot
hypothetically even be defended by any
pawns and often that's because the pawns
which could defend the square are now
one step further
in this case the E and the C pawns have
advanced to the fourth rank they cannot
themselves defend a square in the fourth
rank so of course this gives the Knight
potentially a massive outpost on D4 but
what a lot of people don't understand is
that just because the whole exists
doesn't mean that you want to occupy it
ASAP we should start with the move
Knight C6 but not because we're gonna
play Knight D4 on the next move it's
it's way too early to occupy the Outpost
because we don't have any other pieces
developed and if we put a knight on D4
straight away then White's just gonna go
Knight F3 and knock our Knight off of D4
it's more the long-term weakness that's
going to cost white later on down the
line when all of the development is
complete
but the other thing that we get is we
get a potentially massive diagonal for
our dark squared Bishop Knight F3
so here there's kind of a really
interesting moment the move that we are
going to play is G6
but if I were playing a classical game
you know a real over the board game and
somebody played this against me I
actually would play a somewhat different
move I would play the move E6 or Knight
F6 and after the game I'll talk a little
bit about why but
the basics of why should be clear to you
what does the move G6 allow white to do
should white want to transition to main
lines what is the drawback of the move
G6 here yeah of course it allows white
to push the pawn to D4 and after D4 C
takes D4 Knight takes D4 we transpose
and we're gonna play G6 directly to the
marozzi bind variation of the
accelerated Dragon but since we're
putting the emphasis on openings I
actually wouldn't mind that but from a
purely objective standpoint the way to
quote-unquote punish white for playing
C4 is of course not to allow a
transposition to main lines it's to put
pressure on the E4 Pawn try to prevent
white from playing D4 in a good version
but hopefully my logic makes sense and
our opponent has played D3
um and that that solidifies the hole on
D4 and after Bishop G7 we're flat out
better out of the opening we've got
great pieces and we're dominating the
dark squares in the center
and of course not not to mention the
fact that White's Bishop light squared
Bishop is now essentially a big Pawn
so hopefully we'll get some marozzi's a
little bit later Knight C3
and now we can continue our development
in rather normal fashion so in general
in such positions it's uh a
self-evidently good idea
to trade our light squared Bishop four
whites uh Knight on F3 so imagine if
these pieces are gone from the board
that's a good thing to kind of do right
to visualize certain minor pieces
disappearing from the board what effect
will that have on the position well if
the Knight on F3 disappears then clearly
our control over the D4 Square only
increases and at that point we can
seriously start contemplating already
putting a knight on D4 which will be not
quite unassailable actually quite far
away from unassailable because white can
still use the dark squared bishop or
even the C3 Knight to trade the Knight
off but both of those moves are
associated with a lot of awkwardness and
the best way to threaten to trade the F3
Knight is of course to play the move D6
which again also just improves our
position and is a normal developing move
but I like the move D6 a little bit more
than Knight F6 I actually think that we
probably should delay the move Knight F6
until a more opportune moment has
occurred and as you'll see we actually
can develop the Knight to E7 which is
very common in the Sicilian okay now we
proceed with our positional plan we
develop our Bishop to G4 we continue
clamping down on the D4 Square we trade
a piece that controls that square
this is like sort of very classic
positional chess 101 Bishop E2
now what a lot of people struggle with
in a situation like this is like okay do
we actually proactively take on F3 or is
there no hurry so it doesn't matter
right you can take on F3 or you can
continue your kingside development and
both options are good we're going to try
to emphasize like classic rudimentary
positional play so I'm actually going to
eliminate this Knight while we still
have a chance the drawback of not doing
that is that the Knight actually could
have moved away and the trade of light
squared Bishops is okay for black but
it's not quite as glamorous as getting
rid of White's Knight and again I'm
going to repeat what I said earlier
there is no hurry to put the Knight on
D4 right we can do it here we can play
Knight D4 and you can say well after the
trade Bishop takes D4 Bishop takes D4 we
now have uncontested control of all of
the dark squares right our dark squared
Bishop is now operating uncontested
that's a good thing Knight D4 is a solid
move but we're gonna practice restraint
and what we're going to do instead is
find a developing Square for the G8
Knight such that it doesn't obstruct our
own control of the D4 score which would
be the weakness of the move Knight to F6
so if we play Knight F6 here later on we
might then have to drop the Knight back
down to D7 for example to increase our
control over D4 but instead if you've
played the Sicilian a good amount you
should know that there is what was
introduced to me as the buttvinic setup
and I think this has several different
names the botnik setup is how I was
taught uh that this is the name that I
was taught
and the bobbining setup simply entails
fiancettoing your dark squid Bishop then
carving out a alternate developing
Square for the G8 Knight with the move
E6 specifically with the movie 6 or E5
yeah the bovenic stuff is also E5 so we
play E6 and then we get this Knight out
to E7 and the reason we do all of this
again is to make sure that our dark
chord Bishop is still uncon is
unobstructed right we don't want our
Knight blocking our Bishop also the pawn
on E6 is kind of an asset it's
controlling some important squares it's
controlling D5 it's controlling F5 we're
creating kind of a a toothy Construction
in the center
where our pawns are are kind of like
Teeth you know controlling all of these
important squares uh yeah E5 I don't
like you I mean E5 would be a very bad
move here E5 would be a very bad move
because it would just return the favor
right we don't want to create a weakness
of our own on D5 also we don't
necessarily want to block in the bishop
like that
okay so now Knight G7 notice how
harmoniously our pieces are placed every
piece is sort of clearly occupying a
well-defined role
and our general strategy is to continue
clamping down in these Center squares
we're making it very very hard for white
to basically to move
in earlier speed runs I've mentioned
that in the Sicilian you want to avoid
playing E6 and G6 in the same breath
this is a totally different scenario
because the center is closed the caveat
to that rule is that when the center is
open you often don't want to combine the
moves E6 and G6 because it creates dark
squared holes here these holes are
totally inaccessible because White's got
a bunch of Pawns in the center
so okay like why can play a move like
Knight B5 here big whoop it's a total
paper tiger it doesn't even threaten
anything we can just Chase it away with
A6 that's also why when we played the
movie six we shouldn't worry about quote
unquote weakening the D6 Pawn because
the D6 Pawn is well protected by the
queen and it's essentially unattackable
Bishop G5 by our opponent okay so I'm
most definitely not afraid of white
taking on E7 that actually is what we
want we want white to give away his dark
scored Bishop especially for the E7
Knight which relatively speaking is the
the inferior the most inferior of our
pieces leaving the other night to jump
into D4 so what I like here is to sort
of lure white you know it's a prod white
into taking on a seven on the Move H6
the reason I don't like the move
Castle's King side quite as much is
because of the move Queen to D2 in
response and at that point white is
already threatening to trade the dark
squared Bishops and I use the word
threatening deliberately right it is a
serious positional threat we most
certainly do not want to get rid of our
dark squid Bishop that is our the pride
of our position so by playing H6 we are
doing two things we are of course
provoking our opponent into taking on E7
but if white drops back to H4 which is
very likely doesn't happen then we would
be able to castle kingside without
fearing that White's gonna build up the
battery and trade Bishops with Bishop H6
hopefully that makes sense so obviously
we take with the queen in order to leave
the Knight give the Knight continued
access to the D4 square and we are not
worried about the king and the queen
being aligned once again because the
center is closed Queen A4 okay the
Knight is pinned our next move is
obvious we need to complete our
development by castling kingside and
finally we have exited the opening and
entered the middle game black is much
better I wouldn't say that we're winning
probably if I had to throw out an
evaluation I would say it's maybe minus
1.5 minus two something like that so
it's a very serious advantage and and
again just notice the control that we
are exerting over the dark squares a
white cannot move white is just totally
stuck what is a bad bishop and now we're
going to start the process of converting
these sort of abstract positional
advantages into something more concrete
I think this is what a lot of people get
anxious about they're like well yeah I
get it hypothetically and I get that
we're much better but how do we actually
make something of these positional
advantages and this is I think hopefully
going to be the instructive part of this
game so of course there is the move
Knight D4 which we can play now we can
play it a little bit later let's let's
set that aside Knight D4 is not a plan
Knight D4 is a move and if we play
Knight D4 here White's gonna drop the
bishop back to D1 White's probably not
going to allow us to take on F3 and ruin
the pawn structure on the king's side
so if you've played the Sicilian for a
good amount of time there there is a a
stock plan in such positions that I
think is perfectly applicable here and
this plan will probably involve the move
Knight D4 at some point essentially the
plan consists in developing a queen Side
Pawn storm but also to open up files on
the queen side and when you are when
your pieces are placed in Superior
fashion compared to your opponent's
pieces usually opening up the center
opening up flanks is going to benefit
the side with better place pieces what
plan am I talking about what is this
mysterious plan that opens up files on
the queen side well it's to prepare a
very particular kind of Pawn break and
this Pawn break uh is involves the move
B7 B5 that is the pawn break itself and
to prepare it to prepare it we should
start with the move A6 very unassuming
looking moves A6 and if you look at this
situation tactically you actually might
notice that B5 is given if things remain
as they stand now B5 is possible on the
next move we don't actually even have to
prepare it any further so if you do some
calculation after B5 if white plays C
takes B5 a takes B5 Queen takes B5 then
the Knight can jump into D4 and not only
will we be able to take the bishop and
ruin the king Side Pawn structure but if
we want to be materialistic we can jump
into C2 notice that the moment a rook
appeared on you one I'm already thinking
about Landing a knight on C2 especially
because of how accessible that square is
through D4 okay so I'm combining
tactical observations and knowledge of
typical plans in this type of position
and in this a6b5 plan is is virtually
Universal in almost all anti-sicilians
and when I say anti-sicilians I mean
non-opened Sicilians open Sicilian being
white uh playing the move Knight F3 and
then D4 that's open Sicilian anything
else is considered basically
anti-sicilians so let's fast forward
again to the current position we've just
played A6
again notice that I am not rushing the
move Knight T4 I'm keeping this for the
most opportune moment H3 so our opponent
is not actually taking any action
against V5 so what's interesting is that
we don't have to play B5 immediately I
actually like the thought of going
Knight D4 first so if you look at the
situation carefully after Knight D4 the
bishop really only has one square right
D1 because if Knight D4 Bishop G4 we can
chase the bishop with H5 so after 94
Bishop D1 B5 the White Queen is
virtually trapped if you look at that
position carefully because it can't go
back to D1 there's now a bishop there
C2 and B3 are protected by the Black
Knight and if the queen drops back to A3
then we push the pawn to B4 that's
another Fork against the queen in the
night you can actually make a serious
case that B5 in this position is a
little bit inaccurate because it allows
the queen to drop all the way back to D1
and in that situation you might say oh
but then we play B4 and we win the B2
Pawn but you don't quite do that because
B4 white has the move Knight A4 and
white is still hanging on and after B5
Queen D1 Knight D4 you're no longer
threatening to ruin White's structure
with Knight takes F3 check so the effect
of the move has been slightly diminished
so hopefully I've been able to explain
my logic now after Knight D4 a very
Advanced player would actually still
play the move Queen to D1 I think this
is why it's only move that doesn't lose
almost on the spot but that is not an
easy move to play because that involves
sort of understanding why it's a bad
idea to move the bishop back which to
Mesi seems a lot more natural if our
opponent plays Queen D1 then we can
respond with B5 but it's totally worth
starting with this move it's more
flexible and to test White's reaction
and that's not called playing for tricks
right that's called being practical if
you if there's no cost to you then it's
absolutely worth playing the move order
that entails more tricks or that gives
your opponent more rope
but this is this is a pretty minor
subtlety both of these moves would have
been totally fine so you shouldn't think
so categorically about oh you know if I
play B5 that means I made a big mistake
no both of these moves are totally fine
we're talking about relatively minor
subtleties here but even if you're
basically a beginner hopefully you're
able to follow that logic and I'll show
this once again after the game over the
board for those who had a little bit of
a hard time visualizing which is also
totally fine yeah Rook E3 is possible of
course
rookie 3 is possible of course but then
first of all we can still play B5 and
after rookie 3 the sexy move that we
have is actually H5
with the idea of putting a bishop on H6
and Chasing The Rook away once again
Bishop D1 is played and boom was the
dynamite we strike at the other side
with B5 and white is borderline I think
at this point already white is lost
okay and now what is definitely lost
because the queen is literally trapped a
queen is literally trapped and that's
how quickly like at this level when you
know typical plans they tend to work
like a charm I mean this was pretty
extreme but it's not a coincidence that
this type of plan resulted in success
like if you diligently learn and read
about the typical middle game plans and
the openings that you play and hopefully
the speedrun is gonna actually help you
if you want to follow my opening
recommendations you want to build a
repertoire from scratch
hopefully I will succeed in showing you
these types of typical plans that you
can apply on your own games it's over
white has to give the queen away for one
for well the most the white can give it
away for is the real queen takes a it is
technically the best move but in
addition to the extra Queen we have
managed to keep all of the advantages of
the position to begin with so it's
completely lost
now of course
um
Queen A5 here would be the only move to
keep the game going but even after Queen
A5 I think we could virtually trap the
queen
by playing we'll talk about this after
the game but I'm pretty sure before and
then maybe dropping the Knight back to
C6 comes very close we'll check we'll
check Queen A5 we can okay Queen takes a
played Rook takes a eight
and
okay A3 well that's fine with us we can
simply continue our plan
what was that what was our plan well our
plan was to expand on the queen side to
open up files and the move here should
occur to you very naturally of course B4
is like literally begging to be played
especially because the white Rooks are
disconnected which means a takes before
is impossible 92 is good okay so now
again we have like a gazillion ways to
win this
I remind you that in such cases there is
two overarching plans the first is to
aim for simplification the second is to
use the second is my preferred plan you
don't really need to go out of your way
to simplify if an opportunity to
simplify presents itself then you should
take it but you shouldn't necessarily
give away your advantages in for the
sake of simplification this is a great
example you know what I don't like here
I don't like the idea of playing B takes
A3 Rook takes A3 and then trading the
Rooks like that is unnecessary because
our Rook is better than white truck why
are you Trading
okay so in this case I like a move that
keeps the tension now what does it mean
to keep the tension well what do I see
when I look at this what I see when I
look at this is that our Queen is not
really playing to its fullest potential
Knight is good the bishop is good The
Rook is good everything's doing
something the Queen is a little bit kind
of stuck in no man's land a little bit
now think about okay well where can the
queen go we're gonna go to B7 for
example to skewer x-ray the B2 Pawn good
but I'm more looking at White's king and
the moment you look at White's King is
some of you are suggesting you're
spotting the move Queen G5
with two ideas those are the key and
tactical I should notice that Knight F3
check is now a threat which white
doesn't defend against we don't need to
say that twice there's Knight F3 and the
second idea by the way was to infiltrate
to D2 that wasn't the only idea if White
had gone in this position Knight E2 to
G3 we would have infiltrated to D2 with
our Queen for King the rook and the pawn
on B2 winning the game immediately
but this ends it right away
this sends it right away and notice how
quickly we managed to win that it was
like boom boom
whereas if we had started to simplify in
this case
and if we had taken on A3
and then done all this other stuff the
game would have been going a lot longer
Knight takes C1 obviously we take the
Rook you know again
very important rule of converting
material advantages efficiently right at
this point we're up a full Queen at this
point simplification is almost always
Justified but still not really necessary
and yet I liked throwing in B takes A3
just to clarify the situation on the on
the queen side B takes A3
we can grab another Pawn on G2 that's a
free Pawn but it's not just a free Pawn
just look at what it does to White's
King side so this is a no-brainer you
should definitely take free stuff when
it presents itself and a lot of people
like don't keep that straight in their
mind it's hard to explain there's no
scientific formula for like when do you
at what point do I continue taking
material when do I instead go for
simplification in many cases when you're
up like a queen there's like a gazillion
ways to convert and it's largely a
matter of taste so here we should
definitely not fear the progress of the
a pawn because the a pawn is going
absolutely nowhere The Rook on A8 is
stopping the pawn you don't even need to
play Rook A5 even if the white pawn
reaches A7 we're just gonna pick that
pawn off so I like Bishop D4 that's a
great move but I'm just gonna abide by
our strategy of taking free stuff just
let's keep taking take on H3 if
permitted we're going to take on D3
my guess is that White's going to go
Bishop C2 knowing players of this level
but we'll see
okay I was wrong A5 and we can take
another Pawn on D3 and incidentally it
prevents A6
funnily enough this also prevents Asics
so one good thing to do if you're you
know
not necessarily a beginner but if you're
sort of entering intermediate level is
to always question is to always follow
through with a question when you're when
you find yourself being afraid of
something whether it's a past Pawn or
some move never just take that for
granted always try to like figure out
exactly why you're afraid of this thing
and whether you should be afraid of it
Queen drops back to C4 attacking The
Rook pressuring the bishop keeping
contact with the Knight
yeah Queen C4 is obvious without further
comments and of course thank you for the
bishop hopefully white resigns here
hopefully white resigns oh I don't know
why Jeffrey's name is
on the screen that's hilarious
yeah it's because sorry about that
wait this speedrun game is dedicated to
Jeffrey my good friend by the way give
him a follow and if you're watching on
YouTube twitch.tv gmjx he's awesome
all right let's quickly go over the game
all right so yeah so C4 C4 moved to this
has been played against me and again
it's not such a bad move if White
follows it up accurately if White
follows it up accurately so after Knight
C6 Knight F3 let me just quickly follow
up on a comment that I made about G6
technically not being the best move the
reason it's not the best move is because
it allows white to transition the game
back into open Sicilian channels
and obviously like according to Theory
white is better in the morosi bond in
this line this is what's most commonly
recommended by books it's the marozzi
bind with the pawns on C4 and E4 this
position is usually reached via the open
Move order Knight F3 Knight C6 D4
immediately
accelerated dragon and the morosi bind
is defined by the move C2 to C4
as opposed to Knight C3 which is the
traditional accelerated dragon and after
Bishop G7 Bishop E3 we won't talk about
this right now we will I'm sure have the
marozzi probably even more than once but
hopefully my logic makes sense like I
wouldn't mind getting this here just to
demonstrate typical ideas so that's why
we uh we didn't play in more topical
fashion if I was playing a classical
game I'd probably play
uh the move I would probably play Move
E6
now the thing is if white plays D4 here
you actually get a bad version of the
morosi here I can get Knight F6 in
already White's Pawn Center is under
very serious fire
so the pony 4 is hanging if Knight C3 we
can go Bishop B4 and this is considered
a pretty dubious line for white
and if white plays Knight takes C6 BC
and E5 this is worth knowing
anytime you have the pawn and E5 the
king only one like this you should be
thinking about Queen A5 check with a
fork against the pawn and the King
so I don't remember what the books
recommend here but it's probably not G6
of course our opponent makes a serious
positional error he plays D3 and this
defines our permanent domination over
these key Central squares hopefully that
makes sense Bishop G7
let me just refresh to get brighter
colors Knight C3 D6 so as we explained
we're going Bishop G4 and getting rid of
the knight in order to increase and
stabilize our control over particularly
the D4 score but we're not rushing with
the movement id4 this is one of the the
narratives of this game is that we were
patient the control over the square is
much more important than actually
putting a piece on the Square you have
to keep those two things separate in
your mind
right sometimes they're basically one
and the same but a lot of time if you
have a piece controlling a square from a
long distance you don't actually need to
put a piece on a square to assert your
dominance over that square
B6 the botvinic setup putting the 97 to
not obstruct The Bishop's control over
that square
isn't it bad taking on F3 if it's not
force not at all not at all and you
might say well I learned that you
shouldn't
you know make two moves with one piece
and trade it for a piece that's only
made one move and this is a good example
of where opening principles are starting
to get overtaken by concrete
considerations right the center is
completely closed and a lot of
principles and rules simply do not apply
when the center is closed I mentioned
the fact of going E6 and G6 when the
center is closed
virtually everything is on the table
because the center is often the only way
through which you can attack weaknesses
when the center is closed you don't have
to worry about anything
a lot of the time and this is a great
example of that
so I think virtually every speed run
I show you
this very uh memorable game from early
in my career where I played the moves E6
and G6 but I played them when the center
was open and I got burned immediately
and I I can't show this game enough let
me show it again
I ended up winning this game but that's
totally beside the point
super old game from 2005. so watch how
quickly things go downhill he plays the
Smith Moro
plays the Smith Mora
um and I I take and I had no idea how to
play the Smith more at the time
so I was kind of ad-libbing it I played
Knight C6
and at that point I was dabbling in the
dragon so I decided it's logical to play
the move G6
so he plays Bishop C4 already G6 is
considered to be very dubious
so he castles and now of course I had
learned about the butt Finnick setup
so I decided to play E6 and I was like
okay I'm gonna go 97.
and I'm gonna go castles and I'm just
gonna be totally fine and I I wasn't
calculating at all here the center is
open which means the D file is open
which means that these dark squares
which are weakened tremendously by the
movie six are now
easily exploitable by white species and
he immediately pounces no 95 E5 just
gives away the pawn although that is an
idea worth remembering to push E5 to
solidify your control over D6 here this
is not necessary just straight away goes
Knight B5
threatening
an Unstoppable check on D6 but I decided
I'm gonna go Knight F6 and Knight T6
check is not as dangerous as it seems I
can move my king and black is still okay
but rather than 96 he goes suddenly
Queen D6 and I realize I'm busted on the
spot because there's literally no way to
prevent the fork on C7 which in this
case is going to win the queen so all I
had to do was all I had left was the
move Queen E7 check trade and he wins a
full Rook on A8 as it turns out things
were not so simple I grabbed a Pawn on
e4
and although white is completely winning
I was later able to win the night on A8
getting compensation and I won the game
but the
sort of gist of this should be clear
that with the open Center you should be
very careful about these two moves when
the center is closed things The Rules of
Engagement are totally different because
there is no engagement between the
armies
so anyways that's a pretty long-winded
explanation but hopefully
you were able to understand what I'm
getting at two completely different
types of positions
so castles we go Knight G7 Bishop G5 we
played the move H6
and the reason we played the move again
is because if we had castled Instead
This is a worth a worthwhile tool that
you should be familiar with even as a
beginner this battery with the idea of
eliminating the fiancato bishop with
Bishop H6
for example let's make a random move but
white plays Bishop H6 and of course the
point is that if you move your Bishop
you give up an entire exchange so you're
virtually forced in this case to
acquiesce to the trade of your main
piece now if you have allowed this the
the traditional way that you take the
sting out of Bishop H6 is you
preemptively move the Rook you
preemptively move the rook in order to
be able to drop the bishop back without
sacrificing The Exchange sometimes
actually you can sacrifice The Exchange
so this would be fine but it's a little
bit awkward to allow White's Bishop to
sit on H6 like that it's awkward and
it's totally unnecessary
when we can just throw in them of H6 and
what this does is it it takes the sting
out of the move Queen D2 and white can
still play this move
but this no longer threatens anything
um I could probably find an example
pretty quickly of sacking an exchange
yeah just give me like 30 seconds
so this is an old Soviet game pan out
against the Megan see Megan was was a
grand master he was very strong hanoff
of course is a person after whom the pan
of attack and the claro Khan is named he
was an IM
so this position occurs on the board
this is a dragon Sicilian and in the
dragon this exchange sacrifice of Bishop
h8 is very common actually so
having as a student of these ideas you
might think that samagan uh would play
rookie eight here so that you can meet
Bishop H6 with Bishop h8
but he feels that he doesn't have time
for that he he needs to get stuff going
on the other side of the board so
instead he goes Rook C8
okay obviously pan up panov goes Bishop
H6 and
samagan goes Bishop h8 he feels that the
dark squid bishop and the dragon is more
valuable than that Rook on f8 and he is
correct
vanov grabs it he takes back and it's
not like black is winning on the spot or
anything but watch how quickly his
decision to keep the bishop alive pays
off first you go Bishop C4
so the position is very very oops sorry
the position is very very unclear it's
not like black is even better here but
some Magna ends up crushing him G5
Knight ft7 Bishop F1 to H3 by panov now
samagan plays E6 in order to lock the
bishop out of the game
and create kind of again these like
bumpers
that control a lot of the key Central
squares
banov goes King B1
Knight centralizes to E5 and after F4
samagan finds a crazy idea and this idea
directly justifies his decision
to keep the bishop on H6 alive
can anybody find it I'm actually curious
this is not this is a Nutty move and he
was a very strong attacking player
this is a Nutty move and I'm not sure
it's sound yeah Knight F3 is correct he
plays Knight F3
Knight takes F3 and now Bishop takes E3
now he gives the bishop away but for a
much better cause of course the point is
if Queen C3 you take on A2
now the line doesn't end here after King
A2 Rook C3 BC why doesn't Kingdom and a
horse for the queen but it's compensated
by the fact that white White's King is
incredibly weak and White's pieces are
poorly coordinated so for example I
think he was probably intending to move
Queen C8 in order to directly harass
these incredibly weak pawns maybe
prepare Queen C4 check my guess is that
black is doing quite fine here without
checking the engine
so of course he plays BC
and now D5
that Queen is heading directly for A3
so panov drops his own Queen back to C1
to prevent him from coming to A3 but now
the Knight jumps into the attack with
Knight A4 it's like a classic dragon
attack Edie and Bishop takes A2
eliminating a key Defender
King A1 he doesn't take the bishop
because if he had taken the bishop
Knight C3 and queen B4 just look at the
storm clouds gathering around White's
King this is just Checkmate and notice
how safe Black's King is Right Black's
King is totally out of the woods like
it's just a one-sided attack
so instead he tries to hide under the
bishop but the queen still comes to C5
then the Knight drops into C3
and black actually wins in pretty simple
fashion he just plays Bishop takes E6
and in this position there is this
overwhelming threat of Queen A5 and
queen A2 with Checkmate so pan off
seeing no other defenses gives up an
entire Rook to prevent that but now he's
down well he's technically only down
well he's down two pawns but he's also
getting mated and he loses in just a
couple of moves gets Chuck Maybe
um so maybe not the best example but I
think you get kind of the point this is
very very common in the dragon this
exchange sacrifice with Bishop h8 King's
Indian also happens in the samish
variation
so back we go to
our game
yeah so that's about it
Bishop takes E7 of course exacerbates
the situation now our domination has
reached just like Epic
magnitudes because of just just the
control that we have over the game and
now after we complete our development we
focus on converting our sort of abstract
positional Advantage into something
concrete and of course this plan of A6
and B5 which is so so common in
virtually all types of Sicilian
structures
uh comes to the rescue here
um joji extends says what should I do
well whites I I wouldn't say that white
is helpless here but it's it's like
borderline lost
so after A6
if I was playing white here
I would probably start by moving my
queen out of the danger zone the queen
on A4 actually adds fuel to the fire
because B5 comes with Tempo and the
queen actually gets trapped so here
probably we would have played Knight D4
and again if I were playing white
disclaimer White's position sucks maybe
I would try to play A4 to make it harder
to play B5
um maybe I would have played the move G3
in order to create at least a decently
safe Escape score for the bishop B5
Bishop G2
and again after BC DC Rook B8 that
there's pressure on the pawn
B3 runs into Knight takes B3 but white
can survive Rook B1 and white holds on
although with this Knight sitting pretty
on D4 it's going to be very hard
how to find B5 well I have no easy
answer for that you just have to know it
right
I I don't think I would be able to find
a 65. that's a little bit like asking
you know how do you know 9 times 7 is
63. it's almost like memorizing the
multiplication tables it's a hard plan
to come up with a priori you should just
know that it exists in anti-soilian
structures and you're like well how do I
know it exists well you know you read
you you listen and you focus on
acquiring a knowledge of of basic ideas
but it's it's so common that I can
literally just show you a gazillion
examples of that plan being applied to
the letter here's a game of mine from a
long time ago
uh that doesn't even start out with a
sicilian but quickly transposes into one
and you can just see this plan in action
so this was the king's Indian attack but
it kind of transposes into a Sicilian
because I decided to play E4 C5
Knight pd2 Knight C6 so watch what
happens first I do exactly what I did in
the game Rook V8 A4 Bishop G4 so trade
the light squared Bishop because the
light squared Bishop is the least
integral piece in Black's camp now we
drop the Knight back to D7 which is I
mentioned this move in our speedrun game
it's just that we decided to put our
Knight on E7 to begin with same idea we
want the bishop to occupy the entire
diagonal and after Knight D2 guess what
I played you might say I played B5 not
yet don't play B5 here because that
allows a to xp5 and then it gives white
a really nice C4 Square yeah you've
opened the B file but you have now a
bunch of weaknesses on the Queen City
you have to be more patient than that A6
you want to attack with the Pawns
F4 B5 a b a b c 3 trying to blunt the
diagonal B4 again using the pawns to
carve and break through and if white
would have played C4 here it would have
been a very similar scenario to the game
of course my opponent didn't he's strong
he tried to mix things up with E5 but in
the end I pretty easily parried all the
threats and I ended up
uh I ended up I ended up winning the pot
okay at the end of the day he ended up
losing this big Pawn on C3 and I won the
game in the end so I can show you a
thousand examples of this B5 plan but
for now suffice it to say that you
should just this should be the first
thing you enter into your database of
ideas if you want to play the Sicilian
properly
um
okay let's go back to
Speed Run game one more time
and once that plan is set in motion
white is in huge trouble H3 Knight T4
again I would play Queen D1 here I think
this might be the last chance after
Bishop D1 B5
yeah the game is over because if white
would have played Queen A5 first of all
if Queen A3 then of course B4 traps uh
forks forks the the queen of the Knight
so Queen A5 was the last hope
and here I think the simplest is just to
play Rook F to B8 first we defend the B6
Square
right if you play Knight C6 immediately
then white plays Queen B6 so anytime you
have a situation like this right where
the queen basically is only one Escape
Square you should start by asking
yourself well do I actually need to rush
do I need to make a move that carries a
direct threat or can I make a second
order threat a second order threat is a
move that care that threatens a threat
right Rook FB in itself is not a threat
Knight C6 is the actual threat but Rook
fb8 sets it up and Knight C6 is going to
win the game and white can do nothing
about Knight C6 nothing about Knight C6
um if okay I guess there's the move
Knight E2 to open up a pathway for
White's Queen
who can tell me what black should do
against 92. and this is all about being
flexible right yeah Knight C6 was the
idea just now but you're asking yourself
okay but what else can I do in this
position make you the silky go not B4 I
knew some people would fall for this
move it's tempting
but after Queen A4 the queen is
surprisingly safe right what are you
gonna attack the queen with
instead you actually play it even
simpler BC
the B2 Pawn is hanging and white loses
it and with that B2 Pawn goes White's
entire Queen side the position just
white can resign here let me just look
at this takes takes you're attacking F2
your Bishop is now a monster white can't
even play rookie two because now you
take and The Rook anyone hangs well I
can't play Bishop E2 because again of
Rook takes E2 so it is just totally lost
totally lost
um so there's nothing that white could
do after B5 of course after the trade
the queen is literally trapped we win
the queen we push before we activate Our
Queen right we just identify which
pieces and playing to its fullest
potential and of course the idea was to
infiltrate the D2 Square
after Knight F3 the rest is
obvious without comments we just ended
up taking all of white spawns
and that's That's All She Wrote folks
so this actually ended up being a pretty
extensive analysis
um which means I probably will put this
out as its own YouTube video
this was instructive I think this was
our first like top to bottom instructive
game that wasn't decided by an opening
blunder
um so I hope you enjoyed it I hope you
enjoyed the examples
and uh again our our emphasis is on
openings and on building your knowledge
of opening ideas so
it's entirely acceptable to
not play the openings I recommend in the
speeder and I still hope you'll find the
game's instructive but I'm doing this
with an aim toward helping
relative beginners basically start their
opening acquisition of opening
repertoire from from scratch
so the one thing the funny thing is the
one thing I haven't fully decided is
whether I'm recommending Smith Mora or
alep and Sicilian I think since the
openings are so similar to each other I
might alternate them
where can we find accelerated dragon
theory well
there are books on the accelerated
dragon
I don't actually have any of them I know
they exist
but again this is not going to be a
satisfying question but I hope that
through the course of the speed run
that's my vision
my vision is that you like by watching
all of the games you will actually be
able to construct a full repertoire for
yourself we will eventually get games
where our opponents go into the main
lines and that's where we will discuss
Theory and eventually I might put some
of the theory into leech studies I
haven't decided yet but uh you know
let's not jump the gun just yet
how's the Black deal with emeraldine
okay so again
please understand the order of here we
will face the maruti blind eventually
when we do I will talk about it very
extensively
and actually my recommendation against
the marozzi is going to be not Bishop G7
but straight away to play the move
Knight F6
attacking E4
a lot of people here already are going
to play takes on E5 this is like the
first trap but that's not the reason I'm
recommending this line here you have
Queen A5 check
the point of Knight F6 is after Knight
C3 you take on D4
and then you play D6 this is a very
underrated line in my opinion and this
is a very dangerous line for white the
point is simple you're luring the queen
to D4 so that after Bishop G7 there is a
pin going on and you're trying to force
white to lose more Tempe moving the
queen back from D4
now this is a very Dynamic line tons of
players with white end up misplaying
this super quickly we will get this I'm
sure probably sooner rather than later
but anyways let's put that aside for now
thanks for hanging out today
and I'll see y'all tomorrow
[Music]